now to another story we're following the
bachelor as matt james speaks out
90 minutes before last night's on-air
drama with a contestant quitting in
tears and a crash landing
rachel just literally slammed into the
earth
hard the bachelor's first black lead
broke his silence about the show's
racism controversy calling it
devastating and heartbreaking he also
described these photos of front-runner
rachel curcanelle
at an old south party as incredibly
disappointing
do you trust me i do as for host chris
harrison who defended kirknell
in an interview with rachel lindsey is
it a good look in 2018 or is it not a
good look in 2021
matt said chris's failure to receive and
understand the emotional labor that my
friend rachel lindsey was taking on
by graciously and patiently explaining
the racist history of the annabelle
himself
was troubling and painful to watch it's
been a week chris
yeah it's been a big week after harrison
apologized twice
and announced he would step aside there
was a report suggesting that producers
might minimize his role in the remaining
pre-taped shows
with editing but that didn't seem to be
the case last night
and all this raises an interesting
question
could former bachelorette rachel lindsey
replace chris
as bachelor host can we say again how
rachel lindsay how well she handled that
it's hard for me to even think about
being the host
it's really toxic and it's
really really tough and then could i
talk like this
i don't want to be muzzled at the same
time i really don't know
i don't know if that's something that's
for me